Well, it's about that time. Time to
massively expand. Time to dial things up
to 10. Time to fulfill Muhammad's
prophecy in Sahim Muslim 146 where he
said, "Verily, Islam started as
something strange, and it would again
revert to its old position of being
strange just as it started, and it would
recede between the two mosques just as
the serpent crawls back into its hole.
We've seen the DAWA guys crawling back
into their holes. Not in the Zut sense,
but in the our lives just aren't working
anymore and we don't have a plan B
sense. Has there been a single debate
all year that wasn't a complete disaster
for them? If so, I haven't seen it. But
I have seen the avalanche of apostasy
accelerating. I have seen Christians
learning the Islamic dilemma and Muslims
scrambling to find a way to respond.
I have seen Muslims getting brutally
ratioed on X every time they post
something from the DA script. I have
seen Daagandists becoming increasingly
unhinged as their tactics fail. 2025 has
been the worst year for DA ever. But if
you look around, you know there's still
a ton of work to do. So, we're going to
do it. With that in mind, we've got big
big changes coming in 2026. In January,
I'm expanding the team. My wife runs the
camera and such when I record my videos,
but apart from that, I do everything
myself. I put my content together. I
make any graphics I need. I edit and
post. I've made thousands of videos that
way over the years. But next month, I'm
hiring two people full-time and two or
three more part-time for full-time
ministry. I'm bringing in Jai and DOC.
You've seen Jai and DOC school Muslims
on their sources in Arabic, but you've
never seen their faces. They live in the
UK and doc's and ex-Muslim. A while
back, I asked them if they really don't
want to show their faces ever or if they
just don't want to show their faces
because of where they live. They said
it's because of where they live. So I
asked, "Well, if you lived in the United
States, would you show your faces here?"
They said, "Yes." Fortunately for all of
us, Jai is a US citizen. He's been
living in the UK because he married Doc
who lives in the UK. But since there's
no good reason to stay in that Sharia
compliant hell hole, they're moving to
my neighborhood next month. So you'll be
getting two, not one, two, first time
face reveals in January. I'm also hiring
someone to run our live streams for us
because we'll be going multicam and I'm
not very techsavvy. I planned to expand
from just me to a whole team like what
three or four years ago. In my mind,
that seemed like it would be quick and
easy. That's always the case. Every time
I plan something in my head, it seems
really, really easy. But when I try to
do it, it turns out to be somewhere
between 10 and a thousand times more
difficult than I thought. Then I give up
and some time goes by and I eventually
come back to it with a more realistic
plan. So whatever it was three or four
years ago, I wanted to start by hiring a
full-time videographer and editor. Told
people to send me applications. I got a
bunch a bunch of these guys were highly
qualified. I was trying to decide who to
pick so he could move and get to work
and then I realized I don't get along
with everyone.
What if I have this guy move to work for
me and then he annoys the crap out of
me? Then what? So then I contacted three
people I've known over the years, people
I know I get along with from studios
I've been to, and I tried to poach them.
And all three of them basically said,
"Look, we like you, but you seem like
you could get totally cancelled at any
time, and that's not very good job
security for us." And they were right.
Things were bad back then. I was getting
banned left and right. But I fixed all
of that. I also bought a bunch of
equipment back then. Some of it, I don't
really know what it does. People told me
I need it. So, I've got stuff that's
been sitting around for years now. I
checked out places I could rent for a
studio, and I was about to sign a year
lease on a place I liked for $2,000 a
month. And then it hit me. I don't have
anyone else ready. And I'm about to sign
a lease on a studio. What am I going to
do with these big empty rooms? I don't
have all these other people to work with
yet. What do I need a studio for?
So I pulled back doing things the right
way now getting the people together
first and then as we get more and more
momentum we can upgrade step by step as
we go along. The team is coming together
like Voltron in January. We're going to
start with live call-in shows. God Logic
and Inspiring Philosophy already have
live call-in shows on certain days of
the week. We're going to fill in the
other days of the week so that there's a
live call-in show from Muslims every
single day. I want to do a weekly
Trinity versus Tawahed show. Anthony
Rogers is the best on that topic. I
asked him if he wanted to move here, but
he does lots of prison ministry where he
lives and he doesn't want to give that
up, but he did say he's willing to
travel as much as we need him to travel.
I'll have to see what day of the week
works best for him, but I'm thinking
we'll have something like Trinity versus
Tahhee Tuesday or theology Thursday or
something as an added bonus. Anony's
never been very consistent at making
regular YouTube videos, so we might have
him fly in, do a live call-in show with
us, go to sleep, wake up the next day,
and then we can record two videos of him
for his channel before he heads home.
That'll give him a steady supply of
videos for his channel. We're going to
have an all lady show. We've got
warriors like Doc and Hatun and Mary
Harb and others who can wreck Dawa guys.
Imagine a show where Muslim men can call
in and challenge an all female lineup.
It will be psychologically traumatic for
our Muslim friends because Muhammad said
that women are intellectually deficient.
So when a Muslim man loses an argument
against women, he's actually losing two
arguments because his prophets being
exposed. AP is moving here, too, so
we'll probably have an all apostate
show. Muslims can call in and challenge
ex-Muslims on why they left Islam. We've
got a place set up for recording podcast
style discussions. It's set up for three
people. I'd like to get me, Jai, and
brother Rashid together for a through
the Quran series. I think we'd only need
to meet for that like once per month. We
can record multiple episodes going
through a chapter of the Quran and
spread out the episodes for the rest of
the month. So, we'll have lots of shows
with different lineups. This is all
pretty much ready to go. And I don't
think it will be much more time
consuming than what I'm doing now
because it'll be a team of people and
Jai is good at all of the stuff I'm
terrible at like staying on task even
when it gets boring posting on other
platforms like Tik Tok. I tried to
figure out Tik Tok. It didn't work. I
need someone to point a camera in my
face and tell me here respond to this
claim for the next two minutes. and then
I do that and someone else does
everything else because I don't know
how. Teamwork makes the dream work. So,
we're ready to start long term after we
get some momentum going. I'd like to
bring in another two or three people who
specialize in some area and one or two
tech guys and editors. What I'd really
like to see is a couple of couches with
five or six people who know their stuff
and just have a live call-in freeforall
every night. Call in and challenge us.
We'll have someone on the team for you.
We do that in the evenings and make
videos during the day. If that works
out, I'd like to start bringing in some
interns. If you're smart and talented
and you end up on our radar, we'll bring
you out to work with us for a year or 18
months or something, you spend the first
four to six months learning the
equipment and programs and such. Then
you start jumping into some shows. Then
we help you start cranking out your own
videos or shows. And at the end of the
internship, we say, "Here's your new
computer. Here's your new camera. Here's
your new mic. We're sending someone with
you for a few days to set up your
recording space.
And we keep multiplying.
Don't know if that'll work or if that's
one of those things that will turn out
to be way harder than it seems in my
mind, but either way, we're getting
started next month. Again, I'll be going
from mainly myself to two full-time
employees and a couple of part-time
employees. This is pretty new to me. So,
I partnered with Defenders Media to
handle all the paperwork and payroll and
such. They said, "All I need to do is
tell people where to donate and they'll
handle everything else." Defenders Media
is a 501c3 charitable organization. So,
if you want to send any endofear
donations, this is the perfect time to
do it. You'll get a tax receipt. You can
also sign up for monthly donations if
you want to support the work monthly. If
you can, I would suggest setting up a
monthly donation. Then once we get
going, decide if the work we're doing is
worth it. If not, pull the plug. But I'm
pretty sure you're going to like what
you see because we've got some awesome
ideas and we'll have everything we need
to get it done. The link to donate is in
the description box.